JOHN BOHANNON: This
is Michelle Casbon.
She's an engineer at
Google on the Kubeflow team
MICHELLE CASBON: And
this is John Bohannon.
He's the director of science
at Primer, an AI startup.
JOHN BOHANNON: My team at Primer
built a machine learning system
that reads millions of
news articles and tells you
what it learns.
MICHELLE CASBON: And
I worked with them
to deploy this
system of Kubeflow
to make it portable
and scalable.
JOHN BOHANNON: The goal
is to create a machine
to help humans learn
about the world
and overcome their biases.
Humans are biased.
MICHELLE CASBON:
Consider this riddle.
JOHN BOHANNON: A boy and his
father are in a car crash.
The father is killed instantly.
The boy is rushed
to the hospital
and prepped for surgery
with one of the best
doctors in the country.
The doctor arrives, sees
the boy on the table,
and says, "I can't
operate on this patient.
He's my son."
MICHELLE CASBON:
Who's the doctor?
JOHN BOHANNON: It's
a paradox, right?
Father's dead, so--
MICHELLE CASBON: It's
the boy's mother.
JOHN BOHANNON: For those
playing at home, don't feel bad.
85% of people are
stumped by this question.
It even worked on Michelle
when she first heard it.
MICHELLE CASBON:
Bias is powerful.
All humans have
it, and we all have
to work against it constantly.
JOHN BOHANNON: Every
time you meet someone,
you can't help but
make assumptions.
MICHELLE CASBON: But
you're probably biased.
JOHN BOHANNON: Wait.
That one's actually mine.
MICHELLE CASBON:
And that one's mine.
Oh.
JOHN BOHANNON: You're
totally biased.
MICHELLE CASBON: Well, any
system built on human decisions
will inherit human bias.
JOHN BOHANNON:
Consider Wikipedia.
It has grown into the world's
most important general purpose
information resource, but
there's no one in charge.
Information is added
to Wikipedia day
after day by millions
of volunteers.
It just boggles the mind
that such a thing can exist
and that it actually works.
Wikipedia aims to be the
summary of all human knowledge,
but it has biases, just like
the humans who create it.
MICHELLE CASBON: If you think
about all the new things we
learn about the world each day,
keeping Wikipedia up to date
seems impossible.
It's not just that important
information is missing
from most articles, but it's
that many important articles
haven't been written at all.
JOHN BOHANNON: Which shouldn't
be that surprising, right?
MICHELLE CASBON: Well--
so there are about five
million Wikipedia articles.
JOHN BOHANNON: In
English alone, yep.
MICHELLE CASBON: And there are
some thousands of news articles
published every day.
JOHN BOHANNON: Hundreds of
thousands, just in English.
MICHELLE CASBON: So you
just have to read all of it.
You find the important
information that's in one
set and doesn't
exist in the other.
OK.
Yeah, that's hard.
JOHN BOHANNON: Machine
learning to the rescue.
I decided to start by
focusing on people.
We want a system that just
reads all the news, every day,
and learns new information
about everyone,
not only people
described in Wikipedia
but anyone described
in the news.
And if there's enough
significant information
about someone in the news
who's missing from Wikipedia,
the system should just write you
the first draft of the article.
The goal is to
make it as easy as
possible for the human editors
of Wikipedia to do their job,
and the first step is to shine
a really bright light so we
can see where our bias is.
MICHELLE CASBON: For example?
JOHN BOHANNON: Well, for
example, only about 15%
of Wikipedia's biographical
articles are about women,
and that gender gap is
especially bad for scientists.
If you never hear about all
the amazing women of science
and engineering, then
it reinforces your bias
about those professions.
MICHELLE CASBON: Exactly.
And that's why I wanted to
work with Primer on this
in the first place.
JOHN BOHANNON: Right.
And here we are just
a few weeks later,
and we're actually
catching up on where
we are with deployment.
So where we left off, we had
this really cool ML system
with some really classic
ML deployment problems.
MICHELLE CASBON:
Kubeflow to the rescue.
JOHN BOHANNON: Our first
problem was scaling,
so the computing load is all
over the map on this one.
On any given day, we're
processing hundreds
of thousands of documents-- news
articles, scientific papers--
and we're updating information
about people in our knowledge
base.
But we also have
users who might want
to add thousands of
new people all at once,
and that kicks off a
back-fill of information
about those people from millions
of historical documents.
MICHELLE CASBON:
This turned out to be
easy to solve because your team
had already set up a Kubernetes
cluster.
Kubeflow is built on Kubernetes
is because scalability
is baked into the platform.
The application
back-end was built
on top of Postgres, which
was a straightforward
migration into Cloud SQL.
Once the data was migrated,
I transplanted the full app
into Kubernetes Engine.
I started with a
single node cluster
and enabled auto
provisioning, which
scales the size of the
cluster up and down based
on resource requests.
So now we can deal with
unpredictable and bursty
computing loads like yours.
JOHN BOHANNON: OK.
But on top of that
scaling problem,
I've also got a
complexity problem.
So our data pipeline has a
bunch of spaghetti junctions,
and not only do
we have thousands
of models to load
at inference time,
but we have to
update those models
as new information comes in.
So at training, it adds up
to millions of model features
getting updated every day.
MICHELLE CASBON: I noticed that.
Well, luckily, this is exactly
what Kubeflow is designed for--
composability.
The platform provides patterns
for reusing common ML tasks,
like updating
models incrementally
in the background.
I started by carving
out pieces of the app.
For example, model
training was refactored
into a separate service that
uses Kubeflow operators.
The monolith is now separated
into smaller, distinct pieces.
Now it's a pipeline with three
separate steps, train, serve,
and web app.
JOHN BOHANNON: Oh,
that sounds much nicer.
OK.
So how's it looking so far?
MICHELLE CASBON: Well, the
refactoring immediately
reduced the training runtime,
so that translates directly
to cost savings.
And now you don't have to
run huge nodes all the time
because GKE takes care
of the scaling for you.
Well, the other win is the
decrease in code complexity.
That translates to less
maintenance overhead,
less time searching for the
source of bugs, less time
on ramping new engineers,
and adding new features.
JOHN BOHANNON: OK, but
that creates a new problem.
MICHELLE CASBON: What
haven't I thought of?
JOHN BOHANNON: So now we
have all this saved time.
What am I going to
do with all my time?
MICHELLE CASBON: You could
create some Wikipedia articles
about women of science.
JOHN BOHANNON: Hmm.
Good call.
Oh, and what about the last
thing on my wish list, about
vendor lock-in?
We don't want our system tied
to one cloud infrastructure.
We want it to be able to
deploy anywhere, even on prem.
Oh, and bonus points
if the solution
is free and open source.
MICHELLE CASBON:
Check and check.
As long as you're running
standard, open source
Kubernetes, you
can run Kubeflow.
JOHN BOHANNON: Wait,
Kubeflow is open source?
What?
MICHELLE CASBON: Yep.
Thanks for listening.
I hope that hearing
about this project
lowers the bar for
trying it yourself.
The Kubeflow community
has some great resources
for getting started, which
you can find at Kubeflow.org.
JOHN BOHANNON: And, hey, got
a few minutes of free time?
I've already used this
machine learning system
to identify thousands of
notable women of science
who are missing from Wikipedia.
You can make a
difference right now.
Just follow this link
and see what the machine
has discovered for you.
Go fill in a gap in
the world's knowledge.
[MUSIC PLAYING]